i should say that
we do have meteors that we see these are
rocks
that by chance happen to collide with
the earth
and they if they're small they burn up
in the atmosphere but
if they're big enough uh tens of meters
or more
hundreds of meters the outer layer
burns up but then the core of the object
makes it through and this is our chance
of putting our hands around an object
if this meteor came from interstellar
space so
one path of discovery is to search
for interstellar meteors and with the
student of mine we actually look through
the record and we
thought that we found one example of a
meteor that was reported
that might have come from interstellar
space
and another approach is for example to
look at the moon
the moon is different from the earth in
the sense that it doesn't have an
atmosphere
so objects do not burn up on their way
to it it's sort of like a museum it
collects everything that kind of rocks
from out there
deep space yeah and there is no
geological activity on the moon
so on earth every 100 million years you
know we could have had
computer terminals on earth that could
have been a civilization like ours
with electronic equipment yes more than
100 million years ago
and it's completely lost you cannot
excavate and find the
evidence for it because in
archaeological digs because the earth
is being mixed on these time scales and
everything that was on the surface more
than 100 million years ago
is buried deep inside the earth right
now because of geological activity
fascinating you think about by the way
yeah
but on the moon this doesn't happen the
only thing that happens on the moon is
you have objects impacting the moon and
they go
10 meters deep so they produce some dust
but
the moon keeps everything it's like a
museum it keeps everything on the
surface
so if we go to the moon i would highly
recommend regarding it as an
archaeological
site yes and looking for objects that
are strange
maybe it collected some trash you know
from interstellar space
you